all right glow yeah glow uh where you
from urgent where'd you grow up
California what part hey Bakersfield
Bakersfield huh and tell me about your
family you grew up with both your
parents you're raised no no my mother my
father took off um and I didn't get
raised to him just my mother did your
spend time with your dad
I called him one time when I was 17 and
he told me that I was doing the holidays
and he told me that he was spending
Christmas New Year's as his family and
have to get back to it so when I hung up
I figured 17 years without him 17 more
will hurt
so I haven't talked to him since and how
was your childhood uh
wonderful my mother was the homemaker
and Sunday school teacher all wrapped in
one she made everything even down to the
bread baked bread till I was about 10
years old and I was very sick in school
so she would make homemade food for
lunches and stuff like that she's good
mom that's great and what kind of kid
were you in high school
I didn't do well in school I was very
shy not a social so I didn't do too well
in school but I made it to the 11th
grade and then I went to work instead of
finishing school at home that was better
financially for me mother
and what age were you when you when you
looked home um it was late bloomer I was
20 and where'd you go la huh for a while
yeah yeah kid I have one son and you
raised him I did yeah just like me it
looks just like Lee hmm he's a good kid
finish school great grades went into the
service
no pregnancies no children no marriages
no drugs no good kid right-handed okay
you did a good job yeah and so now
you're living on Skid Row
I am how'd you end up down here um well
I had been in Lancaster and I was
staying with a guy and he decided to put
me up against the wall and then hit me
and push me out the car and I didn't get
you how he hit me and when I was in the
car then leaned over grabbed the door
pushed me to go yeah so I figured Elliot
wasn't hurt
I figured Lancaster wasn't gonna give me
if anything was gonna get me and take me
and take me out of somewhere I figured
might as well be LA so I came here with
a couple kids so it's a couple young
kids I was like their aunt for a while
and they started they got into drugs
real heavy and needles and stuff and I
can't go that direction because my body
won't let me so they split and I ended
up staying and Here I am and drugs are
part of your life um I do I do crack on
occasion my body won't let me get
addicted to anything my body shuts down
I'm very unhealthy on the inside there's
a lot going on so the outside is kind of
a fool but hey if it works then that
works I guess so use crack sometimes I
use crack I'm I used marijuana on a
religious basis it helps everything
makes me feel of it helps me to eat
calms on all the stuff that I'm supposed
to take medication for so that's
probably my main advice and I smoke
cigarettes and I drink when I can like I
said my body is the judge on that and
how are you surviving out here what do
you do for money you're I'm on
disability I'm disabled yes
yeah so I have that getting to come and
I'm looking for like an RV type
situation right now and should within
the next month's of three months should
have an RV and to be at least off the
street someplace where someone can't say
you got to get out oh not for me
it's it's rough I mean the roughness
it's not for me it's what it is how many
years have you been that's here ah oh
I've been on Skid Row three months four
months
oh that's it yeah you're brand new here
yeah still get lost when I get turned
around wet paper sack syndrome mm-hmm
pardon welcome to the [ __ ] oh well
thank you glad to be here huh the worst
place but what better place to start
over and prove that I can survive throw
it at me let's go yeah so how was your
childhood Oh huh my childhood well my
younger years was great it was really
good my mom took care of everything she
was awesome
the only well kind of untypical I went
through twelve stepdads the longest one
was ten years yeah twelve stepdaughters
yes yeah I'm married how many times
twelve and to her according to her all
of them should have been my father so it
was kind of hard to understand how men
were supposed to be because there was so
many different and it got to the point
where the only thing I really learned
was when things got bad when you get hit
when you get hurt pack up and bail and
that's one of the few things I've been
really good at
my third stepfather the one that was the
10 years and had raised me and when they
split I went to live with him for a
while and for whatever reasons he didn't
look at me as a daughter anymore and it
was confusing I didn't talk to anybody
about it I'm just not the type to talk I
had three more that had done the same
thing my mother's not aware of it it
didn't tell her so when the last father
happened my mother and I we were
visiting in LA somewhere in LA I don't
remember at the moment and we were at a
hotel she was a long-haul truck driver
at the time and then husband wasn't
there and I was visiting her and her and
I had to make it a little short we were
robbed at gunpoint and she was raped and
I was beaten with the gun they never
found them and I didn't talk to anybody
about it but that was the last husband
I've only been married twice my first
husband he tried to kill me with his
medication I don't like to cook so I am
a cleaner and so he was preparing meals
and putting his medication in my food
and by the time I went to the ER the
first time the doctor said he has to
talk to me in private and he said honey
I don't know what's going on but you
won't make it to the ER a second time if
you don't get out now so I got out and
then my second husband ended up
committing suicide huh but
I'm okay still and it's okay can um
there's a lot that went on in between
different things and I'm just having a
hard time bringing them out to surface
my mom ended up coming down with
dementia and my son hit a hit a trip in
his real life and decided you didn't
want to speak to me so in my head my
mother left me and my son left me
because I have I have a bunch of
psychological dysfunction depression
PTSD anxiety so on and I didn't handle
that well so within a year say from like
January to Christmas by the Christmas
time I managed to not pay my bills so
inappropriately that I got an eviction
notice right before Christmas and since
then and I haven't been on the street
but by the time I got to the LA area
living situation became a little harder
and then the relationship situation so I
didn't I didn't and I still don't really
know what I'm supposed to be doing but
I'm just looking for the help to try to
get back on track being down here when I
first got here I was in a situation with
someone that there was a big fight and a
blow-up and I left and about dream
two-and-a-half three months ago now I
was walking just at night in LA I don't
remember where I was somewhere in some
Asian part over in the towns and I had
the last thing I remember was I ended up
talking with someone and then when I
woke up the next morning I was filthy
and the bottom half of my clothes you
were beside me and I'd had a big ol head
right here and I'd been raped
in the apartment I was talking about
that I've managed to get myself evicted
from I had two attacks in that apartment
I was waiting for somebody to show up I
was getting some weed and I don't I
barely remember think remembering I
think I remember somebody knocking out
my back door the next thing I remember
was I woke up in my living room on the
floor completely naked and completely
bruised up I had been it had been an
attempted rape but I had fought hard
enough that didn't get what he wanted
but he tried there were all kinds of
bruisings out here I had been hit beaten
up but didn't get what he wanted now the
second attack that was a little more
violent and this one I do remember so he
have to forgive me it's a little
difficult but I'm there again I was
expecting somebody to show up wasn't for
drugs or anything just to hang out and I
have no memory of this one also except
for certain parts that stand out it's
like a selective memory I was put up
against a wall that was beaten badly my
left arm was broken and my right ankle
was framed
and I had been
II I had been raped so badly that I was
put in the hospital for a month
they didn't catch the guy because I
don't remember his face and I can't I
can't
I guess convincingly or with solid fact
could put him at the place that was
difficult but um again I managed to get
through it and Here I am when I was in
LA for that short time I was down with
the girl that used needles and she
brought a friend over to the place we
had rented and he had brought a couple
friends with him and everybody was using
needles to do heroin and and speed and
the one drug I don't like and I don't do
I have been known to do it but the
crystal that's a weird drug but anyway
it ended up turning into a half way kind
of like sex party and I'm not really
into those and when I went have to
excuse myself my girlfriend that I
thought was a friend at the time ended
up being the I guess the controller of
the situation and I ended up getting
tied up beaten
and they cut me and it burned me
this happened for most a week
they put drugs in me they tried to force
alcohol down
but I ended up throwing that up and that
has made them mad so that's when they
taught of burning and credit me I don't
I don't make too many female friends
anymore they've never really been too
great with me
treating me like a plague but again I
lived through that and I'm still here
doing a few years in between
I managed to find boyfriends that you
know pretty sick and demented if they
were jerks take me and
ended up going out being a partner just
like a guest however they do it Chuck
drivers the guy that I was dating and
for almost a year him
had threatened to kill my mother if I
didn't do what he did or just why I
stated he had pimped me out to other
truck drivers and it didn't matter what
they wanted drugs if I wonder if they
won the girl to do drugs whether I
wasn't do or not I was forced most times
they tied me down sometimes there was
more than one I had planned to try to
kill him down to make and because of
whatever situation that guy was going
through I'm still uncertain he had taken
off and for whatever reasons not not
come back so he disappeared and he left
me in Iowa I had to try to come back
here my mother was here in California
she had put my face on the back of a
milk carton box
because of the first rape in the
apartment and I was told I wasn't going
to be able to ever have children the
first child that I had the first two
children that I got pregnant what they
were an emergency termination my body
wasn't helping it until the third time I
found out I was pregnant I decided to
have the baby I he ended up being almost
10 pounds at birth and to take him out
in cesarean but he came out good but
they had a complete hysterectomy because
there was so much damage from the attack
and from him sorry I keep bouncing
around
I had a friend guy friend I thought
we're friends I'm not sure what a friend
it really is um I had known him for a
few months and then he'd gotten to
telling me about his religion he was a
Satanist I'm not you're all around
average religious type person but I
don't give credit to anything evil good
or bad because I know what I know and
I've seen what I've seen when he
threatened me it was after my son and he
had threatened to kill my family if I
didn't do certain things that he hated
wanted and because of fear I'm not
believing in my own strength I ended up
being filmed I ended up being out in
public doing things that normal people
just don't do I don't know how much I
can come into bed
[Music]
it was like in someone's garage when
they make a stage and they have a board
where they have leather typing where
they type people up yes ma'am use
different objects for different things
whether it hurts you or not that's not
part of the issue this one on 4.0
I finally got all of my mother at one
point and I let her know a little bit
about what was happening she helped give
me the strength to be able to prepare
for what I need to do for protection to
be able to leave yeah I was able to
finally it was a dark night he just
wasn't known he was there a lot and
usually everything's locked so I can't
leave but he had a window that he'd
forgotten he knocked they had not locked
and I just left with what I had on and I
was so scared because if he did come
back I'm still scared now because if he
ever finds me I'm dead but I hope it's
just me and not my family I can handle
that
because of the stuff that's happened to
me and being just born mental I'm not
able to walk much anymore and I have to
be careful with anything physical into
did I take yes if you forgive me I've
never told but touching anybody about
anything ever ever not anyone none of
this ever happened to me it's not the
only way I've been able to make it alive
and I'm the type that me it's guiltily
but if you don't talk about it it's
never happened
if it's never happened to you you can
live and I barely live EE ever existed
since I've been homeless
I've lived for me in spite of the rape
in spite of the attacks in spite of the
drugs in spite of people people yeah I'm
not prejudiced I hate everybody equally
there's no age just good age race get it
but if you're gonna hurt a child or an
animal or an elder person step in the
way and I have before I would step in
between some guy getting ready to beat
the hell out of another woman and tell
me hit me hit somebody that's ready for
you
don't hit somebody weaker
Oh God and the attack in your hotel room
that's what brought on the fibromyalgia
disease so that makes it a kind of
everyday reminder as much as I want to
kill nine out of ten people I see I'm
gonna don't think murder ever business
right if I could I dream of jeannie' it
all better and make it all good kid
and I can't put a gun to my own head I
can't check out in this life so I have
to keep fighting these people good I
have to try to help protect the ones
that can't do it and there's not enough
of me everyday too hard to keep going
and now I don't have anybody I don't
talk to my mother anymore she could be
dead I don't talk to my son I wouldn't
talk to me either
he's a dove like me so I have no witness
but I'm ok with that
I'd rather just have meat that way I
don't have to be the bad thing at
anybody's life you know aside from the
12-step dance when I was younger that
was nothing my mother made every holiday
a complete production she made all my
clothes she home cooked all my meals she
was God the devil the police the
teachers the principal she was
everything she made everything perfect
did that all of a sudden the divorce of
my stop that 12-step dad I think that's
the only thing that started it and when
he touched me that put me in another
left field that up they got ever go back
to for whatever reasons I had the
ability to pick the most abusive
individuals to be around her to go out
with I'm not sure why she was a great
mother but she also had to be very badly
she was abused by both her parents she
received so many beatings in place of
her brothers and sisters she was almost
killed
so she overprotected be
it really messed me up how old were you
and you were lost by your stepdad I'm 14
and I never told anyone about that cuz
you just don't tell people that Fitness
because they'll do something to turn
around and put it against you huh
so I've just learned to keep everything
quiet I've learned to deal with it
myself yeah it's got me beef yeah it's
got me in situations that usually see
how movies and it's got me homeless I
mean but what are you supposed to do
where are you supposed to go who are you
supposed to go to so you learn to turn
it in where didn't you learn to make all
those bad things about somebody else cuz
they don't happen to you you can breathe
and so I can't speak
[Applause]
and when the armed robbery took and took
took place when I had first opened the
door I didn't even check the lock or
check to see who it was because mama
said open the door honey
no mommy knows everything so I did what
I did the guy hit me in the face with
the gun and shattered my job that's when
after that they did the robbery and they
raped my mother and they had to beat me
unconscious because I kept trying to
stop them but they were hurting my
mother and you don't hurt her
and I couldn't help that it happens to
me that's one thing don't let it happen
and I couldn't have but she's okay -
she's still breathing I hope he's still
alive then I hope to see her again one
day I know I'll talk to my son
I had a friend Toby you know why you
can't kill yourself I said cuz I'm a
chicken he said no good you're not a
coward nobody in my life has ever said I
was not a coward ready he wasn't much of
anybody but that meant the world to me
so when somebody says don't worry I got
you
you're protected no don't
if they get through you they're good and
get to me I've already been gotten to
and I'm not gonna have it done any more
by anybody now I can't there's not
enough of me then if I have to be alive
all this wretched earth then damn it I'm
gonna fight and I'm won't stop I'll
fight any but and I'll fight till I
can't fight anymore but you'll have to
kill it to take whatever you are not
gonna get it easy
you didn't whoa
I wish I was like King Kong for just
like five minutes got even shortened to
thirty seconds just let me just let me
call her what I can't adjust that time
does that tell me
let me big and strong have a power
behind that punch not o mosquito ha ha
ha
but what can you do you can change
things you can fix things you can add
things but you can't give more power you
can't gain size you can't go from Minnie
Mouse to King Kong that's not fair
but nobody ever said anything's fair
right damn I hate that I don't know what
you're gonna do so my goal now is to
keep that peacefulness in my zone keep
that constant calm in my life there are
no exceptions for anyone at any time
ever because if it's not an easy flow
it's not a part of me
but I am Who I am and that's all that it
is and if nobody likes it you don't have
to be around me cuz I can be alone to be
just fine nothing I'd learned that
there's anything I've learned the most
important thing ever
it's not how does a fight survive I
don't live without anybody you can't get
hurt no it's already hurt begins to heal
enough to be able to smile every morning
grab this world by the balls and smile
and laugh and make people laugh all day
because everybody wants to be miserable
that's too [ __ ] easy
alright well thank you so much for
telling me your your story you're
welcome
and I hope it was whatever it needs for
whoever sees it yeah it's very powerful
you've been through a lot yeah yeah well
we all have thank you for sharing
you're welcome thank you for asking me
Oh where's my vodka I need a coffee
you